Welcome to the vlog guy.
So today we are going to talk about the top three programming languages for data
science. And before we do that,
I want to talk about my life because I'm a YouTuber and I'm a narcissist and I
need constant validation from you guys. So a little update, um, I'm in LA now.
So I'm thinking a short vacation because then I felt a little bit burnt out from
work.
So I wanted to chill and do nothing for like a few days and the
perfect person to do that with my brother. We have a special guest,
David ma, and this is what we did when we were here.
Yeah.
But since I'm an aspiring filmmaker, that's how I saw it
Anyways. So I'm going to go back home now, uh,
going to have to go find a scooter so I could scoot back home. Uh,
see you later.
They see me rolling. They hate
Petroliana try to catch me
[inaudible] okay. All right.
This is my bed. This is the Nintendo switch.
I've been playing a lot of Celeste. Super fun. All right. Let's get started. So,
so I'm going to answer this question real quick,
and I'm going to answer it for data science analytics,
because that's what I know.
So the top three programming languages are Python R and
sequel. That's it?
[Inaudible].
And I actually don't even like answering these questions because it's just so
different in terms of the languages and their use case. Like for example,
SQL isn't even the programming language,
but I still put it there because it's quite important to have,
or at least to know how to use it, because no matter what data you use,
you have to use something to query it.
So that's SQL and I wouldn't even consider having to learn SQL because it's
basically just the tool to grab data out of the database.
So in some ways it's kind of saying like learning how to use windows, computer,
or learning how to write URLs, to access the internet.
Like I'm exaggerating a little bit, but that's kind of how I feel about it was.
So here's why I chose Python as number one,
Python and R both have the best packages related to stats are the
programming language is basically made for numerical computations.
So that's why ours has a vast range of statistical packages that you can use.
And they're all open sourced, even more so than Python.
But the thing about Python is it wasn't built for numerical computation or for
stats or anything like Python was built for clear programming.
It was built for code readability.
So then Python got more attention from developers. And then because of that,
developers would soon start to develop more frameworks or libraries to support
the Python language. Like for example, web frameworks, like flask, Django,
they were all built for Python. And then, because it's so popular,
it also drew attention from the stats people.
And they probably really liked the language because it's clean.
So then that's why the stats people started developing, you know, psych kit,
pandas, Jupiter, notebooks, everything that you need to make the disco analysis.
And it's a little bit of a virtuous cycle because the more you have support for
numerical computation, the more people will use it.
And because the more people use it,
the more frameworks will be developed and more support it would have.
So for example, TensorFlow for machine learning,
they provided a Python API and a C API.
And the reason they provide a Python API, I'm not sure.
I think it's because Python is so popular amongst the machine learning
developers or set suspicions,
or maybe even the data scientists and quants because Python is already so
Poplar,
then TensorFlow decided to have an API for Python and C.
So basically Python is just super popular and it has tons of resources online
and more and more people I feel are moving away from AR and starting to use
Python for statistical analysis. They use Jupiter notebook.
It's super nice because it's a way to organize your notebooks and a way to
present your analysis are, is still a very, very good option. And I mean,
when you think about it, art is literally built for statistical computing.
So it's pretty good. However, it is less flexible.
Like imagine if suddenly you want to start making websites, you're kind of,
you're not going to make a web backend using AR there's no frameworks for that.
I don't think so. And finally, sequel, you just need it.
You're just going to need it everywhere. No matter what you do it,
you don't even need to be a data scientist.
You might be just be a software engineer and you want to query some data for
testing purposes or maybe to validate your feature or something like that.
You're still going to need to pull that data somewhere.
And usually it's from a database and in most database, except for no sequel,
most relational databases, they use SQL as our language.
So you should just know it.
So that's pretty much it that's top three programming languages for data
science. Now I just want to thank rom Sans for supporting this channel much,
much appreciated. And also Joshua pop asked, what is one social thing?
And one technical thing you wished you learned in college that would have helped
prepare you for the tech industry? Well,
the thing I will say is not super tied to tech industry.
It's more about me as a, as a person and my personal growth,
but the one social thing is I wish I was a better leader and
communicator at work.
If you take initiative and you communicate really clearly what you're going to
do and what for you'll do a lot better than most new grads,
I was always a bad leader. You know, I,
nobody listens to me and I'm not very assertive.
So I wish that I was better at that. And also, you know,
I have sometimes trouble communicating what's on my mind and my ideas,
or even my roadmap to my peers. And then because of that,
I get affected negatively. So I wish I was better at that.
So for the technical thing,
I wish I learned iOS development because if ever I want to quickly prototype an
app or an app idea,
then I can do it a lot easier if I know iOS development and most of the apps
nowadays, they have a mobile component to it.
And because I didn't know how to do iOS development,
I couldn't execute on some ideas that I wanted to cause I just suck at front
end programming. And I feel like that's been always my limiting factor.
I just really suck at front end development. I can quickly build API APIs or,
you know, web back ends with databases and all that, that stuff is simple. Man.
Front end suck so much anyways, before I go,
there's a quick word from our sponsor today, by the way,
this video was sponsored by brilliant.org,
which is kind of cool because I actually used trillian.org.
When I was applying to my untitled large company,
since the company gave me links to help me prepare for my interview.
And one of the links that they gave me is a bunch of competent torics questions,
AKA probability questions on brilliant.org.
It really helped me on the map part of the interview because I was killing the
probability questions.
I actually find it really fun to crank out these questions.
It makes me feel good about myself and keeps me sharp.
And they're good brain teasers for interviews,
especially for data science or quantum.
Very good supplement to my interview preps. So highly recommended. Also,
if you're in school,
you could supplement your learning by using this website because there's a wide
variety of topics, which is pretty dope.
Cause I love the UI on the website and it makes studying so much more fun with
their quizzes. If you're interested,
there's a link in the description down below, best of all,
you can get 20% off their premium subscription. So YouTube,
you can kill it at the interview for the large entitled companies.
All right, then that's it for the vlog. I hope you enjoyed this video. Uh,
now I'm just going to add some random clips so that I could extend this video to
10 minutes so I could get more ad revenue. So I guess,
I guess you can watch me play video games or something.
[Inaudible].